so I met my half-sister when I turned 30
and I was sitting in my backyard and I
had an idea a moment so I was think I
knew of them growing up but i never knew
them i have a half-brother and a half
sister and I was sitting in my backyard
and I think maybe because it was the
moment where my wife and I started
thinking about having kids you think
about your family and you think about
where you came from and this image
struck me and it was the last image of
the movie and I had no idea who there
was these these you know adults watching
themselves as children never having
known they played together and I had no
idea how where it came from but it just
sort of struck me and I didn't know who
the characters were in the in the image
but I I felt it so deeply and I sort of
put it in my pocket and I walked into a
party that night and a woman walked up
to me and said I'm your sister so I took
it as a sign and I started writing and
it took eight years to write this movie
many we wrote it it was that it was the
labor of absolute love and passion you
know between the big projects and
sometimes even during the big projects I
think the thing that kept us feeling
like we were in balance but yeah it was
it's been an amazing ride well I had to
writing partners I had Bob who's my
regular writing partner in Jodi who's my
was a dear friend of mine from college
and I really felt strongly that this
needed to be a piece of material that
was an actor movie and and Bob and I are
so trained I think now in this in the
structure of action screenwriting that I
didn't I didn't want to bring that to
the equation and I didn't want to be
thinking in those terms and I wanted
someone in the process who wasn't going
to be you know weighted down by that and
because Jodi was an actor and I trusted
him very much I felt that he was going
to have very good instincts for were
scenes needed to live and it was the
first and only movie we've never
outlined we usually have a very rigid
outline but we decided not to because I
think we felt that we wanted to follow
an intuitive sense of character and
nothing else we didn't want anything
else to be going on there and we went
down a lot of wrong roads that
why I took eight years to get the script
right well once the movie was happening
Chris Pine was the first actor I asked
to do it and he said yes and we had
known each other from check and we were
very friendly but not we weren't close
we were friendly and we got extremely
close on this movie and I I felt
strongly that he had the ability to you
know you've got a character who starts
you know on the one hand being this guy
who's totally cut off from anything
really spilling spinning a thousand
plates and he's really aggressively
trying not to deal with his life and you
end the movie with this same man
standing on the door stunna sisters
doorstep just utterly vulnerable saying
take me as I am please forgive me I want
to be a better man really and and that I
loved the idea of that arc and I felt
that chris is a guy and he's like he has
a sort of a buoyancy to the way that he
played Kirk and trekking it in some in
some ways you know if I if you ask me
what Trek was about I would tell you the
story was about a you know a young
rebellious guy with dad issues who takes
his first step into adulthood by the end
of the movie and I could be describing
this movie and so I felt that he had it
and and you know then you kind of worked
the gene pool out from there um I saw
amazing amazing actresses for Frankie
and and they were so many of them so
wonderful and when Elizabeth came in she
just was Frankie she just she blew she
blew me away she was so um I think my
biggest worry with Frankie was that she
I don't want her to be heavy every time
she walked in a room because the
character is carrying a lot and you've
got these to act you know these two
characters who deal with the problems in
their lives they've developed all this
armor they've grown up with all this
armor and one of the pieces of armor is
humor I loved the idea that these two
would look at each other and be utterly
defenseless against each other armor
because it was the same armor and came
from the same man really you know so
Elizabeth has this beautiful ability to
take a line spin it any way I would ask
her but she's also a natural comedian
and in a wonderful way and they had an
instant rapport and I just felt like a
click and then one day I got a call that
Michelle Pfeiffer
was interested in the movie and you know
my jaw sort of hit the floor and and we
I went to meet her and you know that I
had only one reservation I mean I've
been such a lifelong fan of hers but my
only reservation was that I really felt
that Lillian you know when we first meet
her it's probably the first time she's
put on makeup in a year she's been
sitting by her dying husbands bed for
you know a long time and I and I wanted
to be true to the to the rawness of that
experience and I met her at a deli and I
walked in and she had a pair of glasses
here in a pair of glasses here and my
thought was my first thought was that's
in the movie and then we sat down and
she you know very quickly said you know
I want to do whatever needs to be done
for this part to be real and in about a
minute I knew that we were going to be
best pals and we really were and she
should never not for one second was
worried about how it was like if she was
worried she didn't show me about how we
were laying her she was very open about
it